in Belgard right up on Ukraine's border
the Christmas lights are going up a
treat Russia's robbed its neighbor of
this winter bombing the energy grid
prompting rolling blackouts
Ukraine employs a touch of payback here
lobbying shells across the border the
number of casualties in the nearby
Villages small but growing
you can see the damage from the shell on
that roof and this used to be a home one
woman was killed in her garden here the
war coming home to Russia and a tiny
micro level in this thin Slither of land
along the border
foreign
at a Communist Party headquarters in
Belgrade volunteers hand out food and
clothes to ukrainians who fled East into
Russia most of the refugees we meet are
reluctant to show their faces scared of
what they've heard about the hunt for
collaborators in areas recaptured by
Ukraine
foreign
[Music]
her daughter fled to Poland she says she
cannot know where her mother is now
foreign
have been asking if they have a
Christmas tree back home than if the
Russians will destroy it is
why did you come here was it because you
knew that your children would be safe
Australia
she's staying put in Belgrade a decision
which has cost her friendships and all
contact with her sisters
her eldest son will be 18 soon and he's
also staying in Ukraine this is what she
says he tells her
mama
foreign
foreign
s won't have to experience that she's
teaching them in Ukrainian still as well
as in Russian trying to create a space
where they can be the children they were
before all this began Playmates not
enemies in this unwelcome new reality
dynamagne Sky News Belgard Russia